welcome to the show friends neighbors
companions consorts I apologize for my
absence yesterday not to get too graphic
but I did wake up Thursday morning a
sweaty
coughing feverish mess fortunately today
I woke up just a sweaty coughing mess
but without without much of a fever so I
think we can get through this I'm gonna
give it a go I think we'll be okay if I
hack up a lung in the process of the
show don't be alarmed I do have a second
I have a backup log so I should be I
should be fine
I really wanted to do the show today
because I I need to talk about the
Democrats in Congress trying to pass
trying to revive I should say the Equal
Rights Amendment and you you probably
know one of my favorite pastimes is to
debunk the silliness of feminists and
there is nothing sillier than the Equal
Rights Amendment silly being a being one
hell of an understatement here before we
talk about this something that you need
to understand if you don't already which
I'm sure you do is that feminism has
become the most vacuous useless movement
known to humanity
women these feminists are desperate to
be oppressed but sadly for them they
live in the freest and most prosperous
nation on earth very unfortunate for
them such as their luck they want to be
oppressed but they can't be because
they're free and even in the context of
even within the context of this free and
prosperous nation they are arguably
among the freest and most prosperous
inhabitants inside it so but they can't
abide this they just can't they want to
be persecuted they need to be persecuted
and their greatest persecution really is
that they aren't persecuted but they
can't say that so instead they go out
looking for boogeymen
to fight which brings us to the Equal
Rights Amendment there was an attempt in
the 70s to get this ratified but it
failed now Democrats are trying to pick
it up again and they're trying to do it
literally by picking up where they left
off in the 70s they needed one more
state to ratify in order to to pass it
now they have that state and they want
to just take that and run with it rather
than going through the whole process of
getting all the states all 38 that are
needed getting them all again now this
obviously it seems to me from a
procedure standpoint alone is totally
illegitimate it's been five decades if
you want to do this again you need to
start from scratch in fact even Ruth
Bader Ginsburg who is a fan of the
amendment has said that if you want to
do this you got to start over you can't
just you can't just pretend the last
five decades didn't happen so that's the
procedural end of it what about the
amendment itself well here's what it
says it says equality of rights under
the law shall not be denied or abridged
by the United States or by any State on
account of sex simple enough sounds
harmless right on its own except that at
a minimum just to begin with it's
entirely useless and pointless it's
already illegal to discriminate based on
sex this is already illegal not only is
it illegal but there are there are no
examples that anyone can provide of
actual legal sex based discrimination
against women not only that but
women in America today have it very very
good better than almost anybody else
point being the system and the laws are
working quite well for it for women so
this amendment at a minimum is redundant
and useless but it's worse than that of
course because it actually opens the
door to a number of far left agenda
items which is why they want to pass it
and we'll talk about that a minute
before we get to that let's actually
listen lest I be accused of making a
straw man out of my opposite or a straw
woman I suppose out of my opposition in
this case let's actually listen to the
Democrat women on the House floor
explaining why we need this amendment
we're gonna listen to what they have to
say but before we do that a quick word
from ancestry.com you know it's one of
the one of the ways you can understand
yourself and who you are and how you
ended up here is to go back and look at
your ancestry and learn your family
history and that's what's so fascinating
about it is that as you're learning
about your family you're also learning
about yourself ancestry DNA can reveal
ethnic origins and provide historical
details that bring unique family stories
to life ancestry DNA doesn't just tell
you which countries you're from but also
can pinpoint the specific regions within
those countries giving you insightful
Geographic detail about your history
this is very this is we're not we're not
just talking broad brushstrokes we're
talking about very specific information
about your your family history you could
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
learn how and why your family move from
place to place around the world no other
DNA test delivers such a unique and sort
of interactive experience it's easy to
start making discoveries with ancestry
you can grab an ancestry DNA kit start a
free trial to amplify your discoveries
and you know I've done this myself and
the first thing I could at least for me
the one one thing that jumped out at me
first of all it's how easy it is to do
and how quick it is I thought this would
be a long sort of drawn-out process but
you send in the pack it's very easy to
make it very easy on you you get the
results back a lot faster than you think
you will and for me it's been extremely
illuminating to see my own ancestry sort
of unfurled in front of me
you could start exploring your family
story today head to my URL at
ancestry.com slash Matt to get your
ancestry DNA kit and start your free
trial that's ancestry.com slash Matt
that's ancestry.com slash Matt okay now
here are the Democrat women in Congress
explaining why this equal rights
amendment is needed we'll start with the
renowned legal scholar Debbie
wasserman-schultz here's what she has to
say after nearly a century the Equal
Rights Amendment is on the cusp of
ratification at America's founding women
were intentionally left out of the
Constitution as second-class citizens we
lack the right to vote hold most jobs or
even own property today we still receive
less pay for the same work and we face
violence and harassment just for being a
woman but the ER a will prohibit all of
that in the eyes of our most sacred
document we will finally be equal
women's rights should not depend on
congressional whims or who occupies the
White House these basic fundamental
rights must be guaranteed but if we want
to hand a more perfect union over to our
daughters and I have two of them we must
seize this moment to end sex
discrimination we owe it to the women
who sacrifice before us and all of our
daughters and sons who deserve a life of
true equality so I urge my colleagues to
vote YES on this resolution to remove
the arbitrary and outdated deadline for
ratifying the e.r a I yield back okay so
what reason does she give us women are
paid less for the same work well that's
not true
okay that's a lie and you're gonna hear
this lie from every Democrat arguing for
this amendment in spite of the fact that
even aside for being a lie there's
already an Equal Pay Act on the books in
fact sex based wage discrimination is
illegal from about ten different
directions already and it's not like
those laws have proven somehow
ineffective women are not paid less for
the same work the 70 cents on a dollar
or 80 cents on a dollar whatever figure
they're pulling out of a hat the way
that they get that if it's based on any
kind of reality at all it's based on a
broad comparison of all females versus
all males in all kinds of jobs in other
words we're looking at the general
average of what all women make and
comparing it to the general average of
what all men make across the board this
is most assuredly
not comparing the same work so when they
say you know it's an unequal pay for the
same work that is again that is a
bald-faced lie that's all it is they're
just lying to your face about it making
no attempt to conform what they're
saying with reality when you actually
compare women and men doing the same
work the same kinds of jobs in the same
industries and then you further control
for factors like experience level skill
level hoursworked
that sort of thing the wage gap all but
disappears the only way to get this wage
gap is to make a comparison without
taking into account the type of work the
industry hours worked experience level
skill level or anything else the only
way to get the wage gap is to ignore all
of the things that might reasonably
explain a wage gap without sexism so you
have to throw those out to begin with in
totality and then look at the wage gap
in other words the only way to see a
sexist wage gap is to assume going in
that the only explanation for a wage gap
is sexism
and thus discard everything else and
then what do you know look we've just
proven sexism in reality of course men
generally speaking tend to work more
hours they tend to take on more
dangerous jobs which often means higher
pay they tend to gravitate they tend to
gravitate towards higher paying jobs
they tend to prioritize higher pay more
than women do whereas women are gonna be
more focused on you know having more
time with their family and that sort of
thing which is which is great by the way
men also tend to negotiate for more
women are more reluctant to negotiate
for a higher salary during the hiring
process now there's nothing preventing a
woman for negotiating for a higher
salary there's nothing preventing a
woman from you know taking on more
dangerous stuff there's nothing
preventing a woman from moving to North
Dakota to work on an oil rig a woman
could do that it's just that almost no
woman does do that because they don't
want to so all of these feminists saying
oh you know we don't get paid the same
okay I don't see you going out to do
these dangerous jobs that men are doing
and getting paid for them you could do
them you just don't want to and that's
fine but it admit that the reason you're
not getting paid like that is because
you don't want to do the job so this
wage gap thing is absurd it has nothing
to do with sexism whatsoever by the way
are there examples of industries where
in general men make more than women even
within the actual industry itself sure
probably there are also examples of
industries where women get paid more
than men
industry for example the highest paid
female model makes like 40 or 50 times
what the highest-paid male model makes a
similar situation in the reverse can be
found in sports and we hear about this
all the time that if you compare the
highest-paid WNBA star to the
highest-paid NBA star you're gonna find
a similar disparity 40 to 50 if not more
you know why are these disparities in
place well because female modders models
are simply worth more they bring in more
revenue the market is more indirect
interested in them same for male
athletes okay it's not sexism it's the
market place now what else did Schulz
mention as evidence that we need an
equal rights man well she said we women
are victims of violence in America okay
true actually men are victims of at
least some forms of violence more often
than women are men are more or more
likely to be victims of homicide for
example but in any case violence against
women is illegal it's already illegal to
commit violence against the woman we
don't need an equal rights amendment to
prohibit violence against women because
it's already prohibited
yes it still happens because people
break the law but an amendment to the
Constitution is not going to stop people
proactively from breaking the law okay
next we're gonna go to Ayanna Presley
whose arguments for the equalizer moment
are about as crazy as you might expect
but first a word from ring you know ring
is it's so convenient and it gives you
such peace of mind and security and
protection the home that it's hard for
me to imagine going back to a time when
you didn't have it I mean imagine going
back to this barbaric primitive time
when there's someone at your door and
you actually have to answer it
physically in person okay imagine that
you have to get up walk or if you're not
at the house and someone knocks on your
door then that's just it you'll never
know you'll never know they were there
well that's not the case with ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or surprise visitor you'll get
an alert you'll be able to hear speak to
them all from your phone from wherever
you are in the world you could be you
know eight thousand miles away and
you'll know there's somebody at your
door and you can actually talk to them
and and that's been that's been my
experience with ring is it's you know
one of the great things about it is is
just the simple convenience of it of
being able to communicate with anybody
who comes up to your house even if
you're not able to get to the door even
if you're at home but you can't get to
the door but there are different plenty
of times when there's someone at the
door I'm dealing with the kids I can't
get there I've got my phone I could talk
to them that's great but also again it's
a peace of mind the security of just
knowing that you've got your eyes on
what's going on around your house as a
subscriber you have a special offer on a
ring welcome kit available right now at
ring comm / Walsh the kit includes a
video doorbell and chime Pro which is
just what you need to start building a
ring of security around your home today
go to ring comm / walls that's ring.com
/ walsh okay here's here's what I honor
presley has to say about the equal
rights amendment listen the year is now
2028
here we women are still in so many ways
not fully free still shackled today I
rise to affirm the humanity and the
dignity of all women I rise in strong
unapologetic righteous support of HJ Res
79 which will strike the arbitrary
deadline for ratification of the Equal
Rights Amendment an amendment that
should already be the law of the land
women are strong hard-working bright and
resilient we are the backbones of our
families our communities and our
democracy we do not live in checked
boxes we live in an intersectionality of
lived experiences and identities our
issues are everyone's issues because our
destinies are all tied tomorrow's vote
on HJ Res 79 is a vote for the
preservation of our collective humanity
despite our commitment to hard work both
within our households and on the job
we're still paid less than our male
counterparts in addition to pay
discrimination we face pregnancy
discrimination discrimination in the
criminal legal system sexual and
domestic violence and inadequate health
care access but this isn't an accident
the American Constitution is sexist by
its very design first of all can we just
can we back up did you catch
or she said we live in an
intersectionality of lived experiences
and identities did you catch that we
live in an intersectionality of lived
experiences and identities you know that
sentence means nothing doesn't mean
anything
it has no meaning it is a sentence
without content these are just words
thrown together as a signal these are
it's a signal to other far leftist that
she's a compatriot of there's the phrase
intersectionality of lived experiences
and identities means nothing other than
I am an enlightened leftist please
listen to me and take me seriously now
really it becomes it's that's what it's
a signal to other farah letters but to
everybody else to normal people to
rational people it becomes a signal of I
am a vapid empty-headed person just
spouting meaningless words to sound
intelligent please don't take me
seriously that's that's how everybody
else interprets it but I mean the moment
you say intersectionality of lived
experiences I'm just I'm done I'm not
like I can't I couldn't take you
seriously at that point there's no way I
could is there any such thing as an
unlived experience what's the point of
saying lived what's the point of
attaching lived to experience
considering that by definition all
experiences must be lived if you had an
experience that means you lived it
by definition saying lived experiences
like saying vehicular automobile you're
just you're attaching words to other
words to sound smart because you think
that if you if you make if you use more
words than you need to it's it's a sign
of intelligence it's actually quite the
opposite
in any case what reasons does she give
for the amendment other than the fact
that we live in an intersectionality of
lived experiences and identities well
she says the Equal Pay thing which we've
covered and then she says the
Constitution is sexist by design this is
false again women have all the same
rights that men do and even some
additional rights that we don't have
such as the right to kill their children
if the Constitution was sexist that
wouldn't be the case
she also has she also says that women
are discriminated against in the legal
system this is also false in fact women
receive lighter sentences for the same
crimes and are more likely to receive no
jail time at all for crimes that send
mailed men to jail and that is after
controlling for things like criminal
history aside from that she has a bunch
of sort of general platitudes about the
horrors of being women in modern America
and I'll respond to those in a minute
but first let's add Rashida to lead into
the mix thank you so much I rise very
proudly the first Muslim woman ever
elected in Congress in support of House
Joint Resolution 79 I swear it's what's
more even more interesting is what I've
been hearing about is this obsession to
control and oppress women in the United
States of America and I cannot believe
it's 2020 we're still debating the
merits of Equal Rights Amendment
it's beyond time I want you all to know
this is about women of color women with
disabilities transgender women immigrant
women all Dysport these women are
affected by issues like unequal pay
sexual violence lack of access for
health care in poverty so much of what
we're doing here in trying to promote
women's equality is about gender racial
and economic justice so I would ask you
all know this a no vote today condoning
oppression of women in the United States
of America and I urge support and yield
the balance of my time
okay so again the unequal pay thing
that's really all they have and they
don't even have that she talks about
violence against women which once again
is already illegal we don't need an
amendment for that did you know there's
also no specific amendment that makes it
illegal to to attack men
there isn't a specific anti violence
against men amendment
because because that's already covered
under the basic concept of human rights
and
every state in the country has laws
against assault and murder and there are
federal laws against it too and
everybody is covered by that unless
you're an unborn child in which case
women specifically have the unique power
to kill you without any legal
repercussions whatsoever and then she
goes on you were Rasheeda to leave as
well goes on about this oppression of
women saying people are obsessed with
oppressing women who give me an example
give me a real-life actual example in
the United States of oppression against
women
now you could of legal legal oppression
against women now you could give me many
examples which preceded Talib seems
reluctant to do but you could give me
many many examples in Muslim countries
of legal oppression of women that's a
real problem but feminists are too
focused on that instead they want to
find it United States they can't find it
here's the reality now that we've heard
the feverish fantasies of these
ridiculous feminists the reality is this
legally women have as I said all of the
rights that men have you cannot give me
an example of a right that men have that
women don't I can on the other hand and
have already given examples in the
opposite direction the one that I've
already given the big one men have no
rights at all as as they have no
parental rights when their children are
in the womb that's it that's a pretty
big example nothing like that exists on
the other end of the spectrum
discrimination well I already told you
that statistics show that in the legal
system women get lighter sentences than
men can you show me legal discrimination
going in the other direction and this is
to say nothing of the family courts
where women are far more likely to be
awarded custody in in in in in divorce
battles than our men now you could argue
that there's a reason for that you could
say that it's it's it's not about anti
male bias I mean you can't deny that
women are far more likely to be awarded
custody that's just true that's the
truth that's the statistical reality but
you could say oh it's not about any kind
of broad bias against males
it's just that you could argue men are
less likely to fight for custody you
could argue that if a child is going to
be predominantly raised by one parent or
another it's it's better generally
speaking that it'd be the mother you
could argue these things but if you do
you'd be admitting number one that men
and women are different and must
therefore be treated differently even
sometimes in a systemic sort of way a
legal way and that it's possible to do
that in a way that is not bigoted and
then you would also be admitting that
there could be non bigoted reasons for
gender disparities but if you admit that
then you have to go back to any gender
disparities where women are on the
losing end potentially and ask yourself
if this applies to that as well
so if you're going to a knight and I
have heard this justification from
feminists for this Family Court thing
where they say for example while men are
less likely to fight for custody I don't
even know if that's true but but if it
is okay let's go back to the wage gap
women are less likely to fight for a
higher wage in in in the hiring process
so if the one is not anti male bias then
this is not anti female bias and in
terms of just the general condition of
women versus men here's what else I know
women females are more likely to
graduate more likely to go to college
less likely to get suspended or expelled
in school less likely to be put on drugs
for supposed mental disorders like ADHD
in in their schooling years men make up
the majority of murder victims the
majority of workplace injuries the
majority of homeless people the majority
of drug addicts and the majority of
suicides
so I'm not saying that women don't have
their own challenges in society they do
but men do as well and given everything
I've just laid out it's gonna be very
difficult to actually prove that women
somehow have it worse have it so bad in
fact that we need a whole new amendment
to the Constitution to remedy the
problem I just don't think you can
now I have given you real actual
statistical evidence-based examples
unique ways that men struggle in society
if you have similar examples for women
and present them but you notice that
none of these people did they have lies
they have half-truths they have
platitudes
no evidence and if they do they haven't
presented it now so what is the Equal
Rights Amendment actually going to do
well at best it's just redundant and
useless so at best you've added a an
amendment to the Constitution that's
redundant and useless but one thing we
know about redundant and useless laws is
that they end up getting exploited
because usually there's a reason why the
people who are fighting for the
redundant and useless law want it it's
not just for symbolic reasons they
intend to do something with it that they
haven't been able to do with the current
laws that are on the books so the law it
looks on the surface to be redundant but
actually it's not because they're going
to use it as a vehicle for something
what are the fart what are that what are
left it's going to use this as a vehicle
for well a number of things first of all
this could be used as a as a
justification a legal basis for ending
all sex segregation in every aspect of
life
bathrooms sports those would be two big
ones
now we know this is something the left
has been trying to do with respect to to
you know to transcode unquote trans
women that that is that would be men who
are claiming to be women but you get rid
of the segregation completely and now
men don't even have to go through the
trouble of claiming to be women in order
to get access to these spaces
why would feminists want to do that
thereby putting women you know in danger
well that's a good question
but many of them want to of course we
know right away that that that women are
going to be eligible for the draft under
a law like this an amendment like this
but I think the primary thing they're
looking to do with this amendment is to
ensure government funding for abortion
across the country
because what they're gonna do is they're
gonna claim that you know we have
government funding for other medical
things and not allowing it for abortion
is now sex discrimination because women
are the ones getting abortions and it's
a legitimate they say medical procedure
and so according to this amendment now
you're violating this amendment if you
don't give government funding for
abortion so I would say that ending sex
segregation and bathrooms and sports
putting women in the draft that's
probably more of a side effect I think
there are some feminists who really want
to do that again
I can't imagine why because it's gonna
be very harmful to women but we know
that that that this is the irony of
left-wing feminists is that they're
constantly arguing for policies that are
harmful of women I don't think that's
the main but I think the real main
primary point is this it's government
funding of abortion so this would really
be the government funding of abortion
amendment and that's what they're trying
to do
all right let's let's move on I
I needed to talk about this do we have
to yeah but before emails this is
because this is a subject that's very
important to me and very very near and
dear to my heart
personally as a as a tall person who
flies on planes a lot I don't know if
you saw this video that was online
yesterday
it's a confrontation between two
passengers on a flight the one passenger
the woman is reclining her seat into a
guy's lap he doesn't like that so he's
punching the seat to register his
protest yet she keeps it reclined and
anyway watch this
[Music]
there you go now you could argue that
they're both being jerks they're both
being childish some people have asked
why didn't a guy simply ask her to put
the seat back up rather than punching
her seat well maybe he did how do we
know he didn't we're doing this thing
again
where we see an out-of-context clip on
the internet of an altercation between
two people and it's it's it's ten or
fifteen seconds long and we assume
there's no other context whatsoever
widget which which it always ends up
being incorrect because there's always
some kind of context whether that
context will ultimately absolve one
person or another that's a different
question but there's always going to be
a context for what you see it's not like
it just happened randomly out of nowhere
so I agree that he should have asked her
to put her seat up if he didn't ask and
instead just started punching into her
seat then yes he's a jerk but so is she
if he did ask
and she refused or ignored him
which is a situation that many of us
have been in in the past
I'd been in it or you asked nicely hey
would you mind putting your seat back up
you're right you know you're in my space
I'm sure and they just ignore you so if
he asked and she refused or ignored him
and then he started punching the seat
well then he is a hero
speaking of equal rights he's a pioneer
for the equal rights of tall people on
planes this is the point yes the seats
on most planes have a recline function
but most planes also come with no spare
legroom especially for taller people and
by taller people I don't mean 7 feet
tall ok I just mean slightly taller than
average if you recline your seat and
there is there is someone behind you you
are especially if they're over let's say
five eight you are completely taking
away all of their spare legroom and now
their legs are going to be pushed up
against your seat and if they need to
like do some work on a laptop or
something forget it you're not they're
not going to be able to because you've
they can't even open up their laptop
enough because your seats right in their
space you have removed that possibility
so what you're doing is in order to
increase your personal comfort by a
minimal amount you are robbing someone
else someone else's comfort by a
relatively significant amount and if you
don't think it's significant then try
flying for six hours with your knees
jammed up against somebody seat and tell
me that it's not a significant
discomfort so you are increasing your
own comfort minimally
by removing significantly the comfort of
somebody else how could this be
justified
of the seat recliner because because
because the seats can recline therefore
it's okay to recline them that's the
argument I've heard there's a whole
debate now online about us but who's
who's in the right who's in the wrong
and everybody trying to take the woman's
side the entire argument seems to boil
down to well the seats can recline so
that means it's okay to recline them
what kind of logic is that it's that is
the logic of my three-year-old I can do
this therefore it's okay for me to do it
see what a three-year-old doesn't
understand that there are a lot of
things you can do and yet shouldn't
adults are supposed to understand that
yes you can do it but you shouldn't
just like if you're sitting on the aisle
or window seat and there's someone in
the middle seat you can take both of the
armrest
I mean but you know the window guy and
the aisle guy can take both of their
armrests thereby depriving the middle
guy of any armrest at all you could do
that but you should
you can slam a door shut in somebody's
face rather than holding it open for
them you can hit the button to close the
elevator instead of hitting the button
to keep it open as a person's running to
it to get on you can use FaceTime loudly
at a coffee shop while people are trying
to work there are so many things you can
do you can swerve into a parking space
right as somebody's about to back into
it you can ditch your shopping cart in
the middle of the parking lot there are
so many things you can do and yet you
shouldn't because we live in a society a
civilized society and if you care about
not being an a-hole if you care about
being a decent human and not a jerk then
you then you don't do these things that
you can do because they're inconsiderate
and they're boorish and they're rude
reclining your seat is one of those
things it's yes you can do it this is
the seats have that function they
shouldn't have that function
but what you are saying is just so I can
have this little bit of comfort I'm
gonna make the person behind me
extraordinarily uncomfortable
there's no justifying that there just
isn't and this is why
when I am dictator of the country and my
and my rule begins finally mercifully
I am going to take everyone who reclines
their seats on the airplanes everyone
who ditches their shopping carts and
parking lots everybody who's who uses
face time in public I'm going to round
them up at gunpoint stuff them into a
capsule and shoot them directly into the
Sun
you know what maybe not even the Sun
I'll be merciful I could shoot you if
you want to go to a different planet you
know you want me to shoot you to Mars
Mars might be a little too close so I'm
gonna shoot you too - I don't know
Neptune or something we could talk about
that but
just
you are rude on a level that means
you're not fit to live among civilized
people all right now I want to read some
some emails but before we do that a
quick word from our good friends on over
at Rock Auto you know I tell you about
Rock Auto all the time and I'm a huge
fan of what they provide and I just
think that going into an auto parts
store if you got trouble with your car
if you need if you need anything for
your car going in physically to an auto
parts store in the internet age just
doesn't make any sense at all because
what I'm always pointing out is that and
you know this if you've been to one most
of us have that nine times out of 10
what you're looking for they don't have
they got to order it and so you're going
through this whole process there's no
point why not just go to rockauto.com
it's a family business serving Auto Park
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto embody
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything from engine
control modules brake parts tail lamps
motor oil
new carpet whatever kind of card is
whether it's the the car you drive
around every day or it's an old classic
or whatever it is everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door it's very easy to navigate the
site very simple and they got a lot of
unique parts that maybe you can't find
other places and it's also reliably
affordable and cheap you're gonna find
the cheapest options you can at
rockauto.com amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts of car leverty
rockauto.com there's no reason to go
anywhere else
then rockauto.com if you need auto parts
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
Walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
okay all right my voice is holding up
relatively well as we go to emails this
is from Daniel says Matt this is urgent
my dad is legit eating peanut butter
with mayonnaise what in the world do I
do
Daniel the first thing I would say is
calm down don't panic there may be a
reasonable explanation maybe your dad is
engaged in some sort of performance art
okay it's possible so the first thing I
would do is I would ask him give him a
chance to explain himself all right now
and I really think that's important when
Zona was talking about it's all about
context right I was just saying before
and so maybe there's a context could be
performance art could be a science
experiment could be some sort of penance
I don't know if you're if you're
Catholic but but maybe your dad went to
confession confess some horrible sin and
the priest said as penance I need you to
go home and eat peanut butter with
mayonnaise that's possible too so I
would ask him if what you discover is
that he's eating peanut butter with
mayonnaise because he likes it well now
it's time to put dad in a home I think
he is just not you know I don't know how
old you are it's possible your dad's
like 50 but but whatever they however
old he is I don't care it's it just he
is not someone who eats peanut butter
with mayonnaise just and doesn't because
they enjoy it you know this is a form of
self-destruction that I think at that
point you would need to get medical
professionals involved so thank you
though for for that email and my
thoughts and prayers are with you and
your family during this time this is
from Amanda says my sister has always
struggled with her mental health we were
raised in a dysfunctional family but us
siblings have always managed to stay
close throughout adulthood however as
I've healed and moved on my sister's
declining mental health is getting
harder and harder to tolerate I have a
family and I'm happy and I feel more and
more that I that I shouldn't keep
justifying the drama she brings into my
life she lies almost constantly she's
actively trying to ruin siblings
marriages she lies about abuse she
spreads rumors about infidelity within
the family she hates that I'm RELIGIOUS
and she spreads rumors that I'm being
forced into it by my husband and that's
just the tip of the iceberg she's
addicted to drama she can't go five
minutes without telling an obvious lie
she explains away every confrontation
never takes responsibility
I think she could be classified as
delusional telling people she's a
psychiatrist when she's never been to
school
she's been spiraling and her marriages
ending and she has alienated almost
everyone in their life
I'm almost I'm almost all she has and I
feel immense guilt at the thought of
abandoning her especially when she seems
so sick in her mind but I'm at my wit's
end what should I do I need a
non-emotional perspective well man I can
only go based on what you've told me and
there are two sides to every story or
least most stories anyway but I can't
imagine what the other side of this
would be but if what you're telling me
is totally accurate in terms of how it
represents your sister not accusing you
of lying but of course in family
disputes things get emotional and people
can find it difficult to see past the
emotions of it but if that's all
accurate then I would say you should
drop this person from your life like
yesterday it it's not even a difficult
decision to make it may be emotionally
difficult but in terms of knowing what
the right thing to do is this to me
seems obvious because your relationship
with your husband and your children is
way more important than your
relationship with her and if she is
coming in between marriages she's trying
to destroy families
that's that's it that's the it's done in
my view
have to write her off forever but for
now until she gets her act together if
she ever does
wouldn't have a damn thing to do with
her period
lying
claiming that a sibling was was
unfaithful to try to break up a marriage
is that's a one strike and you're out
kind of deal it's one of the worst
things you could do to somebody it's not
that's not that's not that's not one of
those things where you know you patch it
up and you try to you try to move on
from it and then and then and then
that's one of those things where you
have to get the hell away from this
poisonous toxic person and and by the
way I don't think that mental illness
gives people carte blanche to be
narcissistic a-holes to be terrible
humans ketta I don't yeah I think that
those two things are in some ways
separate I mean mental mental illness is
a real thing but character defects are
also a real thing
and character defects is in not a
medical condition
it's just that you have a bad character
because you've chosen to to be a
terrible person and so your sister may
may well have psychological problems but
there's also a separate issue in that
she just sounds like a bad person
even separate and apart from that from
the mental issues trying to break up
somebody's marriage like that that's not
a you know I don't see that as a symptom
of a mental disorder I see that as a
symptom of you're just a horrible human
being and so we just you can't be around
it in fact even if you could argue that
this is all because of mental disorder
so it's not her fault at all even if
that was the case there's still no
reason for you to be around it because
there are more important things in your
life there are more important
relationships your husband is more
important than your sister in terms of
your relationship to him it's more
important to protect your relationship
to your husband than it is to protect
your relationship to your sister your
relationship to your children again more
important so that's what I would do just
I I would have nothing to do with her
whatsoever cut her off completely
and tell her why it sounds like you've
got many many very good reasons and I
would tell her that and I would not talk
to her for a while okay now we we talked
last show I did we were talking about
bullying and what we should teach kids
in terms of how to stand up to bullies
and I'm a I I made the argument that we
need to teach our kids not to be
doormats and to fight back against
bullies rather than always telling them
to quote be the bigger person and run
away tell an adult I got a lot of emails
in response to that so I'm gonna read a
few of them kind of in a row and then
I'll have a general response to hold so
okay this is from Ben says hi Matt I
enjoy listening to your show I think
your stance on the bigger man is exactly
right I was verbally bullied a lot when
I was a kid and was taught by my parents
and teachers to be the bigger man and
not say anything additionally I employed
the god bless the Catholic Church but
man the Catholic schools are a nightmare
additionally I employed the tactic
continuously excuse me to join in with
the bully on insulting myself to beat
them to the punch if you will it was
hell and I developed some serious
personal relationship problems with my
peers because I was never taught to
stand up for myself it is only now after
going to therapy for a while that I have
been able to move past that hurt from my
peers and be able to stand up for myself
I totally agree with you that parents
need to teach their kids sons especially
to stand up for themselves if they do
not then I can personally attest that
those kids will have a hard time being
respected by their peers and feeling
secure and masculine relationships
friendships again thank you for sharing
this my wife is pregnant with our first
and I hope that I can support my child
the way that you have
so that's from Ben okay that was an
agreement not all the emails were in
agreement as you might expect this is
from leo says hi Matt it's Leo first I
would like to mention that you are my
favorite host from all the daily wire
shows you mentioned on the last show the
topic of standing up against bullies and
that it will make you a bigger man by
doing so I've been listening to you for
not too long and I formulated an opinion
that you are just a nominal Christian it
saddens me since I very much enjoy
listening to your arguments and how you
base them I would love and be happy to
be just disproven even though I know you
don't care what me or other people other
people think about you nor should you
Christ's teaching on this topic is so
clear in my opinion turn the other cheek
for instance I was quite surprised that
a mere neh Elementary Christian idea
hasn't even been considered by you a
self-professed Christian when you made
your argument I was tempted to bash you
with all the passages from the Bible
that come to mind but it wouldn't be
consistent with my argument that you are
a nominal Christian so I'm not going to
and my experience as someone who was
bullied a lot in school I have been able
to develop a way of not getting bullied
that is just ignoring the bullies it's
simple as that bullies will always pick
on someone they know they can be
physically in that regard they are quote
smart I have tried retaliating like you
said kids should but got my ass kicked
every time
and this goes on that's the gist of it
this is from Isaac says Wow such study
stunning pillar of ethics you have with
your stance on insulting back after all
the Bible teaches us that our self an
image of our of ourselves is very
important and that when people trample
on you that you should trample back
meekness humility turning the other
cheek many would say is virtue but is
almost certainly just cowardice keep up
the strong moral stance for the
exemplification of the self sarcasm
aside I find your statement that if you
don't insult back when people insult you
because you're a coward is so absurdly
false I can't believe you actually think
that as someone especially bullied in my
life I have had the overwhelming desire
to insult / fight back and it takes
strong willpower to reel those desires
in are you really going to tell me in
your experience where you have insulted
people in your life or got into
arguments with others got into arguments
with others that get personal don't
insult / yell back but rather just cower
away I don't deny that people don't
insult back with insulted but I think
you have the motivation completely wrong
the more obvious reason is they think
that insulting back will lead to more
insults and more people thinking less of
them than if they stay quiet which is
still wrong because it is motivated by
self-interest all the best
hopefully you change your mind or at
least come up with a reasonably measured
response okay so you get the gist a lot
of a lot of emails saying turn the other
cheek and what why didn't I take that
into account when I'm saying fight back
against bullies I'm aware yes the Bible
says turn the other cheek but we
understand that this is not a maxim that
can be applied generally universally to
every situation for example I assume
you'd agree that we shouldn't simply
turn the other cheek when a loved one is
being mocked or abused in that case we
we turn our face towards the situation
not away that's what we should do
this shows that obviously turn the other
cheek is something that we need to
understand with some nuance especially
when you consider that the Bible is
chock full of people most assuredly not
turning the other cheek and this
includes insulting people as Paul was
prone to do
it also includes killing people and not
always in direct self-defense either by
the way these are things that happen in
the Bible sometimes with with either the
explicit endorsement of God or implicit
so I reject the idea that the Bible
calls for us to be meek and mild in all
situations it certainly does not and
such a view cannot survive an honest
reading of the text that's the problem
you know when you come up with this come
away with this very simplistic idea that
the Bible calls for us to be peaceniks
basically never responding in kind at
all never never shouting raising our
voices getting getting angry you know
using violence or whatever it just yes
if all you do is read the Sermon on the
Mount and nothing else in the entire
Bible then I can see where you come away
that with that impression but the rest
of the Bible exists so unless you think
the sermon of the mount cancels
everything else out that came before it
and some of the stuff that even came
after it such as impulsive pistols
unless you think that then I don't know
how you can come away with that
impression that that's that that is all
the Bible wants us to be his peaceniks
so I think it comes down to context
that's what I get from the Bible when I
look and I see turn the other cheek but
then I also see you know much more
aggressive tactics endorsed or even used
Jesus himself uses aggressive tactics at
some points flipping tables and so on
and more aggressive taxes of that
especially in the Old Testament okay so
when I see all of this I'm trying to
make sense of it the only thing I can
determine is that it comes down to
context
now Isaac you said that your decision
not to respond to your bullies was not
motivated by cowardice you say it's
because you had strong willpower but
then you admit that really the reason
you didn't respond is because you didn't
want to be insulted even more so do you
see where I'm going with this that's the
same as someone who doesn't punch back
because they assumed a return punch will
only lead to more punches from the bully
this isn't willpower Isaac that is
indeed cowardice it's not courage and
I'm not saying that that responding is
always the right thing
there can be situations where you just
can't respond or to be very foolhardy to
respond depending on the situation but I
am saying that what you want to consider
courage and willpower simply isn't I'm
sorry it is cowardice and I know that's
the hardest thing to say to someone who
is bullied but there it is
and we've all been bullied okay but yes
you chickened out it sounds like a lot
in your life by your own admission but
we all have okay I have I can distinctly
remember times in my life where I was
being insulted mocked ganged up on
whatever especially in school everyone
went through stuff like this and in some
of those situations I didn't say
anything
I just absorbed it took it was this
courage I told myself afterwards it was
you know I told myself I was being the
bigger person I was being mature
I know the truth now it was it was it
was a total lack of will that it was
submission
it was cowardice the bigger person stuff
the willpower stuff that is after the
fact rationalization of cowardice listen
I'm not saying that when someone insults
you or bullies you that you should seek
to destroy their lives and tear them to
shreds and you know destroy everything
but yeah I'm not saying that okay that's
not what I said all I said is that we
should teach our kids to stand tall to
give back what's dish to them command
respect and not shrink away from
confrontation and this idea that you
should never respond to an insult with
an insult is wrong I'm sorry I don't
think there's any real basis for it
other than an absolutist and simplistic
reading or Mis reading of some of the
texts of the Bible while discarding many
of the other parts of the Bible
so again context is key and I'm also
saying that with our kids in school
especially you know that that is a
context where a little backbone a little
bit of a quick wit a sharp wit is called
for and is right you know why do we
think we have a bullying epidemic maybe
it's because we've given bullies free
rein by teaching our children to wilt in
their presence like fragile little
tulips maybe that's the reason or part
of the reason and as one of the emails
mentioned it's it's it's not even true
that that failing to respond to a bully
is the prudent or safe course most of
the time because otherwise you know you
might risk escalate and like that's
that's the that's the one argument you
could make for not responding to a bully
is that if you respond you're gonna
escalate but that's got nothing to do
with courage though that's just prudence
and that might be true sometimes but
often it's not because bullies bully
because of the high they get from
domination and power over another person
if you make yourself a reliable source
of that high they'll keep coming back to
you for a fix and suddenly this idea of
the high road takes on a new connotation
and when you're in an environment with
the same people for years and years like
our kids are in school if you make
yourself a reliable source for that for
that fix for that high that bullies get
it's going to make your experience
unrelentingly miserable
why do certain kids get bullied
relentlessly all throughout school it's
because they are easy targets and a kid
was an easy target for 12 or 13 years
through all of his formative years of
childhood who has just torn down and
belittled and mocked everyday ruthlessly
a kid like that is going to have serious
psychological damage for the rest of
their lives
there aren't going to be stronger for it
they aren't going to be better for it
they aren't experience of being a weak
submissive does not make you strong
it just it just makes you weaker
they're gonna be worse for it the only
way I mean all we could have all the
anti-bullying policies and measures and
PSAs and seminars that we can do all of
that that we want but at the end of the
day when our kids are actually in school
experiencing this on a day to day basis
and try to get through the day the only
reliable protection we can give them is
to teach them to have the courage to
stand up for themselves
and if they do that you know it's not
gonna be perfect it's not like they're
never gonna have anyone coming after
them but but but if they make it clear
to the bullies that listen yeah you
could you could try it with me but it's
not gonna be easy and you might end up
embarrassing yourself in the in the in
the process
kid who does that it's it's going to
experience bullying a lot less they're
gonna have a lot more confidence in
themselves
and I think that's what we should want
of our kids and I think it's what Jesus
and wants of our kids too
yeah I don't think Jesus intends for our
kids to be just torn down and ripped
apart for 12 to 13 years of their
formative childhood years and come out
with as someone with with no sense of
self-worth or anything at all yeah I
don't think that's what Jesus wants for
our kids I really don't
all right and we will leave it there but
thanks for all the emails for that
interesting discussion and have a great
weekend everybody Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there